Nigeria is pushing Inland to grow its
all reserves by more than a third by
2014.
the move is being welcomed by many
locals who see the potential for jobs
and economic growth
we will have a commercial
oil discovery that will make that will
change the entire photo of Nigeria as at
Large
by exploring further Inland away from
the Niger Delta and NPC the country's
oil company wants to raise daily output
and profits
you are the resisting Transportation
you're also bringing product closer to
its users and you are also having
multiple sources of Supply in the county
that's what it means to us
a new petroleum industry bill was signed
into law last year freeing the country's
oil company from government intervention
although many countries are seeking to
reduce their dependence on fossil fuel
Nigeria says it all will continue to be
in demand if not internationally at
least for its 200 million people this
oil well is the second to be opened in
less than a year and environmentalists
are worried about the rate at which
Nigeria is exploring its oil
activists are demanding more action from
government to hold a powerful industry
accountable the point to the devastation
caused by more than half a century of
all exploration in the oil producing
Niger Delta
preserve our Rivers our streams from the
spillage from the destruction that comes
with all of that careless presumption or
oversight that leads to that poisoning
[Music]
officials say the new investments in oil
will minimize the risk of pollution
the pipeline will be restricted you will
not have any need for doing long
pipelines and therefore because you
approaches interior in the total control
of the environment and the impersonal
environment will be very minimal
but environmentalists point to the
industry's long record of failing to
make good on such commitments
Al Jazeera algebra Nigeria